let's talk about the amazing effects of
fasting on your immune
system the benefits are amazing
especially if you could do a 72
hour fast now with most people you have
to work up to it
but even if you could do a 48 hour fast
that's going to be huge
but definitely work up to a 72 hour fast
and do that
periodically maybe once a month maybe
once every two months but the benefits
of fasting for 72 hours
have more to do with literally growing
a new immune system here's some benefits
number one it'll boost your white blood
cells
but that includes the macrophages and
the neutrophils which
are phagocytes so they clean up debris
they also kill off
viruses and bacteria using different
chemicals and they basically go around
and eat
different pathogens and then we have the
enhancement
of the t cells but especially the t
regulatory cell another name for the t
reg cell
is the t suppressor cell because it
suppresses
an overactive immune system as in a
cytokine storm
as in a situation we have way too much
inflammation that's causing a lot of
collateral damage
so fasting strongly suppresses
inflammation
so there are these things called
cytokines
and there's signaling uh communications
between the white blood cells
that have a lot to do with inflammation
so fasting helps support those cytokines
that reduce
inflammation and then they also support
the b
cells and that has a lot to do with
creating
antibodies in developing memory
from an infection you had so you're
ready and prepared
for the next infection also fasting will
help enhance the weapons
from the white blood cells so that way
they can fight stronger
because there's nothing worse than
sending out an army without their weapon
tree so if you want to enhance your
immune system you will definitely want
to start doing
periodic prolonged fasting now it also
decreases something called
pka i'm not going to get into the woods
with what that compound is
all you need to know is that this
compound
needs to be inactivated for the stem
cells
to be activated and stem cells are the
things that
are recruited from various parts of your
body especially the bone marrow
to start to build a new immune system
and last but not least fasting kills
old and damaged white blood cells
through a mechanism called autophagy so
when you
fast you turn on this mechanism and it
goes after
all the white blood cells that are
inefficient
that aren't working that are taking up
space and it actually cleans all those
up
so you can create space for the new
white blood cells
now for more information on how to do a
fast
check out this video right here